[Applause]
[Applause]
one of the basic truths of the human
condition
is that people love to float
and there's no better place to float
than here
at the dead sea in israel
where without any effort at all large
mammals
can achieve buoyancy
there's some ritual involved to doing
this place the right way
you need to fall into some mud lather up
and then relax with a good read sorry to
do that to your white shirt jack
you handsome devil
israel has many wonderful sides and this
is one of its finest
arabs jews tourists and tv hosts
all come here
and can't help but float together for a
while
and laugh
it's unfettered or at least
less fettered joy
[Music]
it would be nice if this story could
remain so simple
but it can't
to come to israel is to witness the
fierce tensions that loom over this
country firsthand
its spy balloons floating by highways
it's walled off and fenced in arab
cities
and tourist spots turn quiet due to the
stabbings
and random acts of violence that have
become so prevalent
over the past two years
on this episode of hello world i'll dig
into how the constant threat of war
gave birth to the israeli technology
industry
and how israel evolved into a technology
giant
one with thousands upon thousands of
cutting-edge startups
my journey will find me in jerusalem
controlling an ipad with my eyes
at the gaza strip checking out iron dome
up close everything you see here can be
moved out in a matter of hours
and in nazareth i'll meet with a man
that wants to make sure
no one gets left behind in israel's race
to innovate
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello
[Music]
the israeli military dominates much of
this country's culture
[Music]
at 18 years of age men and women head
off for two to three years of required
service
the kids who would be trying to locate
the best kegger or sleeping through
class in the united states
find themselves here dealing with the
most intense of situations
these young soldiers in the israeli
defense forces or idf
also learn to use some of the most
advanced military technology around
to see how the idf has given israel a
unique tech edge
i decided to check it out up close
to see the iron dome
[Music]
i've traveled to ashkelon the coastal
city just south of tel aviv
that nudges up against the gaza strip
what you were seeing here right now is
the launcher
each launcher has 20 missiles on it
you can see uh the red light flashing
which means it's armed and ready
[Music]
here one of the dozen or so iron dome
batteries sits at the ready
to intercept missiles and provide israel
with a type of shield
from aerial attacks i'm the iron dome
commander
lieutenant colonel leron cohen oversees
its operation
is this as close as we get or do we get
this as close as we go
[Music]
it took just three years and about 200
million dollars to develop this defense
system
it relies on a radar that instantly
detects when a missile has been fired
algorithms quickly try to determine what
type of projectile is in the air
and whether it's heading for a populated
or strategic area
if so iron dome launches a missile of
its own
it's said that iron dome has taken down
more than one thousand missiles since it
turned
on in 2011
with a 90 percent success rate
some people question the accuracy of
these figures
what's clear though is that the
algorithms capable of directing
projectiles
while performing a cost-benefit analysis
on human life
are among the most advanced in the world
this network of launchers is highly
mobile and constantly on the move
this site like many is temporary
everything you see here can be moved out
in a matter of hours and we move around
a lot
to make sure nobody knows where we are
all the time
unless you live here it's difficult to
imagine just how much this technology
has transformed the lives of ordinary
israelis
i can tell you from my own personal
experience sitting in
my own house and seeing rockets fired
towards my house
and operating this incredible system
and succeeding with the iron dome when
you see
your house that you're protecting and
your family and your friends and your
soldiers
it's a sense of a great
sense of pride
for many palestinians iron dome means
something else
it's just the most visible part of an
expansive israeli security apparatus
that includes drones checkpoints
and espionage technology
those tools have been put to immediate
use in the west bank
gaza and throughout israel
terrorist bombings have declined
missiles
have met their match but lower tech
forms of protest
like stabbings are now on the rise
[Music]
what's been remarkable is the speed at
which young israelis take these types of
high-tech tools
and then privatize them once they leave
the army
be it peacetime or war israeli
innovations pop up
throughout the world
forget dull strip malls and office parts
[Applause]
the startups of tel aviv come to life
here in the city's vibrant neighborhoods
they feed off the city's energy and the
employees have a chance
to escape their cubicles and live a
little
i came here to meet one of the people
that shaped the israeli startup
lifestyle
[ __ ] kramer served in the idf almost
25 years ago and his first company
checkpoint
invented the freaking firewall
we always had the startup bug so we
always talked about stuff that
we will do afterwards and it was always
around startups
like a lot of israel's tech elite [ __ ]
got his start
with unit 8200 a top branch
of the idf group 8200 right is this is
this famous part of the idf that
i guess equivalent to nsa in the united
states it was
like the bedrock of everything else that
i've done afterwards
as a 22 23 year old i was the head of
the unit
you know 20 people ext you know very
high responsibility
you know i was making decisions in
millions of dollars and
the idf functions sort of like a
never-ending networking event
the first question at a cocktail party
is what unit you served in
for members of unit 8200 these ties have
led to israel dominating the market
for security software and hardware what
makes
israel so well suited to to startups and
technology
there's always a infusion
of new talent from the idf
and the infusion of talent you've got
the recipe for
successful startup nation [ __ ] has
invested in dozens of israeli companies
to see the extreme end of what the idf
can inspire
i've gone to herzeglia a small beach
town and tech hub
that brushes right up against tel aviv
it's here that a company called space
pharma has set out to make some
interstellar drugs
[Music]
if humanity would like to move out of
earth
they must learn the microgravity
conditions
in order to survive on the way to mars
and to other places
ceo yoshi yamin used to head up the idf
satellite program
then he and his comrades hit on a big
possibly profitable idea
they assembled some space software and
science experts
and set to work trying to make life
easier on astronauts
we got the middlemen the astronaut is
not the scientist
he needs to survive we need to eat he
need to train and to sleep
he cannot do too much science
space pharma has built a shoebox-sized
laboratory
that will hitch rides into orbit on
rockets from companies like spacex
the goal is to shrink down
state-of-the-art scientific equipment
and automate how it runs experiments
this would allow a great deal more
science to take place on the
international space station
so we're going to go in the lab okay
thank you for the booties you're very
welcome
so it's a pretty small bio lab but the
equipment's big
and this you can't bring to space so the
whole idea of what we're trying to do
and what we're really going to look at
is how we take this equipment and bring
it down to the small scale
a typical laboratory has
refrigerator-sized machines
microscopes pipettes and a host of
liquids and chemicals
it's a very manual messy process that's
tough enough to pull off
here on earth we just looked at all that
large equipment
this is what we fitted in research done
on the iss has already
led to the development of new drugs and
insights about organisms
molecules floating about freely in
solutions can behave more naturally
than when they're smeared flat on a
petri dish every day our life is
dominated by this lens of gravity
what goes up must come down we remove
that lens of gravity and we learn
something new
space pharma wants to use its machines
to let companies
and researchers conduct dozens of
different kinds of experiments
and to see what space can teach us
to pull myself out of the clouds and
learn more about israel's startup
culture
i went for a walk on the beach back in
tel aviv with another local tech legend
welcome to israel thank you very much
thanks armed with a law degree and an
mba adi sofia tani had led a number of
young companies
and helped spur on israel's technology
economy
now she runs facebook's israel
operations
today we have something like 5 300
startups in israel by the way
it's there's no one country in the world
that has that amount of startups except
the us yes 1
400 new startups in 2015.
1 400 new startups
[Music]
women must serve alongside men in the
military here
adi once hoped to fly jets but because
of the gender restrictions at the time
she ended up evaluating who could become
a pilot
she sees the time in the air force as
crucial to her career
what's the uniqueness of the female
experience
in israel because of the military
service it must have some long-term
effects
yeah i absolutely think it has women in
israel
um probably start their career life
with more confidence with the feeling
that
they also can but are we done in israel
in terms of
women taking part no we are not and i
think that in israel we're probably
because of the military because of
startup nation because of
the culture i think that we're probably
closer to achieve that but we are
definitely still not there
after our chat the d insisted that i go
revel
in tel aviv's famous nightlife
tel aviv stands out as one of the great
surprises of my travels
people head out late here often starting
dinner at 9pm
the bartenders look for any excuse to do
shots with their patrons
and their patrons or at least this
patron
look for any excuse to oblige
the beach the old city
the boardwalk joy rides this is a
wondrous place
that feels at times as if it exists
within its own bubble
separate from the rest of the country
[Music]
from the cosmopolitan coast i climbed
the winding mountain road to jerusalem
tel aviv may be the beating heart of the
israeli tech world
but most jews consider jerusalem to be
the country's soul
and you know what they say about the
soul
[Music]
if you think about it the most basic
thing of human communication
is is eye contact
by the device seeing you you get a whole
other world
of interaction the window to the soul
window
exactly the window to the solar the
window to the brain
look around look to the right look to
the left
yitzi kampinsky is the co-founder and
ceo of u-move
based here in jerusalem the company has
developed a way to replace
eye tracking gear that usually cost tens
of thousands of dollars
with algorithms that can run on an ipad
or smartphone
it's a little disorienting at first to
try and play a video game just by moving
your head
so you see head movement eye movement
iris movement
blinks and then and then analysis of
that
kimpinsky hopes the technology will give
us new
rapid insights into conditions like
concussions
so this is like when they shine the
white light that you have to follow i
mean you see doctors doing that right
exactly
and then based on the score we can tell
if i have a concussion and i don't you
don't have one
i don't have a concussion
[Music]
kampinsky thinks that these hard science
applications with real world uses
distinguish israel's tech scene
especially for jerusalem startups
people are looking for you know real
deep tech
they can't say i'm you know making an
app for taking pictures of food
you have to give a you know a real
explanation to your uh
jewish grandmother about what what is
that for
[Music]
this is the damascus gate it's not that
far at all from where we were
earlier today there's a
sniper up in the window who's guarding
against
a lot of the recent stabbings that have
been going on
jerusalem is trying to turn into a
technology city and this is the reality
of
how these businesses have to come to
life in this type of environment
the moment you step into jerusalem it's
clear that the city carries with it
the weight of thousands of years of
history
everyone in the middle east and by
extension the world
has their eyes fixed here on al-aqsa
mosque
on the wailing wall on the spot where
it's believed jesus was crucified
[Music]
this is a small spot of land with
outsized global importance
under heavy guard
carved into my new slices and fortified
with walls
those barriers went up to curb violence
based on ancient disputes
seen another way they've become
blockades
that hold back modern opportunity
[Music]
i traveled north from jerusalem
to nazareth
the largest arab enclave in israel
a place with a laid-back vibe and a very
specific flavor we can see here
10 or 15 places just for shawarma
so because of that i call it the walmart
valley
you have the silicon valley we have the
shawarma valley and we are at the middle
of the shawarma valley
he opened israel's first arab tech
accelerator
and he knows everyone in town
arabs do not have to serve in the
military and lack the tech connections
supplied by the idf
fadi is set to work trying to fix this
and to help arab engineers benefit
from israel's tech boom
in a controversial move he's linking
them up with the tech moguls who have
come out of the idf's unit 8200
the spooky security and espionage folks
anyone is going out of the a200 first
thing
is thinking about this to make a startup
the 82 undergraduates have a special
ngo that helps them at our community
it's not so
popular to have startup because it's a
new
industry
[Music]
he was the only arab in his class at the
technion
israel's elite technical university
inside of this building he shepherded
dozens of like-minded engineers
they're building software consumer
services and hardware
in an effort to make sure that the
arab-speaking world has the latest
and greatest technology i think if we
can be part of the
ecosystem in tel aviv and to be part of
the startup nation we can
raise the standard of life of the arab
community here because israel is known
as this
startup nation but it's left out a big
chunk of people so
exactly we there's two communities the
arabs and the
jewish orthodox the government now is
putting some money
to find the ways how to engage them with
a
startup nation here because they believe
that if we are not part of that
the startup nation will be somehow
slowed here and it cannot
continue to be the second place after
the silicon valley
[Music]
a handful of his companies have already
taken off and made headway
in billion dollar industries but it's
proven tough for them to find investment
dollars
there's a clear bias against arab
companies and many of their backers have
opted to remain anonymous
or to funnel their investments through
offshore accounts
but fadi remains optimistic i hope in
the coming years maybe we have
big success stories let's say the first
unicorn
start-up from the arab community maybe
here in israel so
this maybe can attract more and more
entrepreneurs to be part of that and
like other businessmen to be part of
this industry
on that hopeful note my time in israel
came to an end
it's understandable that tourists have
made fewer visits here in recent months
that the markets have grown quieter and
the mood in the streets more tense
this place can seem daunting from afar
to visit israel though is to experience
the extraordinary
so many parts of our nature joy
conflict conformity
and imagination swirl around together
in confounding and inspiring ways
i'm not sure that anyone will really
ever make sense of all this
[Music]
but it's spectacular to witness and feel
even if just for a short while
as for my next stop well that would be
iceland
home of alien landscapes an astonishing
amount of fish
and space warlords
[Music]
you